TIMOTHY JORDAN: It
goes all the way to 11.
That's great.
So I'm here with
David Singleton,
VP of Engineering
for Android Wear,
and he's going to catch
us up on all the latest
things with Android Wear.
DAVID SINGLETON:
Thanks, Timothy.
Yeah, so it's great to be
back here again at Google
I/O in the wonderful sunshine.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Every year.
DAVID SINGLETON: Every
year, every year it's sunny.
So what's new with Android Wear?
Earlier this year, we
launched Android Wear 2.0,
which is our biggest update to
the platform since we launched,
all the way back at
Google I/O in 2014.
And with that update,
we were really
focused on making
some of the things
that we see people do
most with their watches
better and faster.
So we start with watch faces.
Obviously, we all love
to have watch faces that
express our style.
But actually, what
we're finding is
that people love to have
information that really matters
to them, right there at a
glance throughout the day.
So we made it possible
for developers
to put data from their
apps onto any watch face
that the user might choose.
And for users, that's
really powerful because it
means you can have a watch
face that matches your style,
but has that information
from the apps that you love.
We made major updates
to the system UI,
to make things like messaging
much more fluid and fast.
And then finally, we completely
revamped the fitness experience
with Android Wear 2.0.
So with 2.0 having come
out earlier this year, what
we are talking about I/O this
year is a lot of new stuff
that we're building
for developers.
And during the keynote, we
shared some of the momentum
that we're seeing for Android
Wear in the category, which
we're really excited about.
We shared during the
keynote that we now
will see 24 brands right now
that have Android Wear watches.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's awesome.
DAVID SINGLETON: And we didn't
say this in the keynote,
but that means
there are actually
46 different Android
Wear watches you
can choose from right now.
And right from the
beginning, we felt
like it's really
important for a product
that you wear right on
your body to be somewhere
that you can express your
personal style and passion.
And so having that choice
of devices, we think,
is a tremendous
testament to that.
Some of the ones I'm
most excited about,
Tag Heuer just launched their
second generation product
which is called the
Tag Heuer Modular 45.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I haven't
seen one yet, is it amazing?
DAVID SINGLETON: So you should
take yourself into our sandbox,
you can see.
The best thing with
this product is
there are all kinds
of variations.
You can swap out everything
from the bracelet
to the little horns to
the bezel on the watch,
and really create a look
that's very personal to you.
And it also has
watch faces that are
personally customizable
to match all of that.
We're also working with some
new partners for the first time
this year.
So Movado, earlier in the
year, announced their product,
and it's really exciting to see
the kind of minimalist design
that they bring to their watch.
And then some of our
other fashion partners,
like Michael Kors, for instance,
have updated their lineup
with a new product called the
Michael Kors Access Grayson,
and one called Sophie,
which you can see inside,
which is a really nice, small
watch, which I'm really excited
will take the product forward
for women in particular.
So we're seeing this
really tremendous momentum.
And actually, that began
before Android Wear 2.0.
So when we look at our
new device activations
for the holiday
season last year,
we actually saw 72%
growth on the year before.
And with Wear 2.0 coming
and all those new devices,
we're really excited that
that momentum will continue
through this year and beyond.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Let's talk a little
bit about fitness.
It's one of the areas
that I'm most excited
about with smart watches
in general, right.
What are some of the new
devices and some of the features
there that you see users
really engaging with?
DAVID SINGLETON: Yeah,
thanks for the question.
One of the things that
we did with Wear 2.0
was completely revamp
the fitness experience.
And one of the things
that we really see
is that what people want
to do with their watches
fall into two buckets, two
distinct kinds of use case.
So one is I'm actually
like, working out right now,
and I want to track
it right on my wrist.
So we call that fit active mode.
You can start fit activity,
you can use all the sensors
on the product--
maybe you're
running or cycling--
to see exactly how hard you're
working, use your heart rate,
compute things like your
distance and calories burned.
The other kind of
experience is just
using the product to set some
goals that matter to you.
Maybe I just want
to be more active
and I want to be active
perhaps for one hour every day.
Set that goal and then
just go and live your life.
The watch automatically
keeps track of your movement,
so we can see how many
minutes of the day
you really were active.
And by seeing that at a glance
on any of those watch faces,
it really helps me be more
active through the day.
And you'll see that right there
on the watch I'm wearing now.
So we find that
tremendously powerful.
But also, smart watches with
beautiful and vibrant screens,
like Android Wear devices, are
a great place to coach the user.
And so with the update
that we recently launched,
we introduced challenges,
where you can do things
like sit-ups and push-ups.
And the watch will actually
show you exactly how to do them.
And then it will use
the sensors in the watch
to see how many you did
and are you doing them
with the correct form.
And that's really cool,
because it means that there's
kind of no cheating.
You can't say, yeah
I did my push-ups.
It is actually going
to count them for you.
And you're going to
do more every day.
And it really helps
keep you motivated.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's awesome.
DAVID SINGLETON:
I'd love to tell you
a bit about what we
have new for developers
that we're talking
about at I/O this year.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I was
going to ask that next.
DAVID SINGLETON: So we're really
excited to build on the things
that we're seeing developers
do with the Wear 2.0 platform.
And in particular, let's
talk about watch faces.
So I already mentioned that
we have the Complications
API that lets your app put
data on any watch face.
But if we turned it around
to the watch face developers,
they can take those
data and actually
render them in any format
that fits the aesthetic style
of the watch face.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Now that's cool.
DAVID SINGLETON:
And that is cool,
because it means that you can
have a watch face that really
represents the particular
visual graphic design,
or whatever it is that
you really care about.
But some of our
watch face developers
have told us that they actually
find it quite challenging
to take all of the
different kinds of data
that apps could provide and
render them in an enchanting
fashion for their users.
So we're making this easier.
We are launching
several things here
at Google I/O that mean that,
if you a watch face developer
and you're dealing with
this data coming from apps,
you can render it really
easily in an enchanting form.
So one is a text
rendering system
that allows you to fit text into
any size region on the screen,
and it will
automatically resize.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's
one of those things that's
not as trivial as you
would think it would be.
DAVID SINGLETON: That's right.
It actually took a lot of work
to make this work really well.
And then beyond that,
we have something
called complication drawable.
And that means that the
system will actually
take care of rendering the
complication data right
where you tell us.
And then we provide some APIs
that allow you to style it,
so it can still fit with the
visual flow of your watch face.
And then beyond
watch faces, we're
also taking a lot of
the work that we've
done to build UI components
and going through the process
of open sourcing it.
So it will be able
to be evolved faster
and you'll also be able to
understand exactly how it
works as a developer.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It's very cool.
All right, so what are
some good next steps?
What are some things that
developers can play with today?
DAVID SINGLETON: So
today, you can go ahead
to the Android Wear website
and you can download the SDK.
You can try out all of the
new APIs I just talked about.
They are live on
GitHub right now, or as
of four minutes from now.
So take yourself over there and
have fun building watch faces
that use the complication API.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
David, thank you so much.
DAVID SINGLETON: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]